hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
questions that Phaedra's opens in his
fairly short and in many respects rather
traditional speech in the symposium is
this one is the beloved or the lover
greater and if we want to say which one
of them is greater we also need to think
about in what sense are they greater
than the other he's not going to answer
this in any sort of conclusive way
although he's going to give us some
suggestions but we can take parts of
what he's saying and you know correlate
them and thank them through a little bit
more this is an important issue that
he's bringing up so I've got this
diagram up here you know the beloved
longer late lover relationship is a
dynamic relationship in the way that
he's talking about it the way that many
other people who symposium are talking
about it it's not a particularly
reciprocal relationship so we're not
thinking of lover and lover we're
thinking of lover feeling something
towards the beloved who may not in fact
be feeling the same thing in return but
they can still be in a relationship
together the longer in Greek is the
Erastus the the one who is doing the
loving the one who is doing the desiring
and
so the beloved is the Roman on the one
who is literally the object of the verb
to love and so what's going on here the
beloved on his side has some sort of
beauty or attractiveness some sort of
handsomeness of charm and perhaps a
nobility of character that would be
attractive as well although that's not
necessarily taken for granted right and
it shouldn't be in the context of the
symposium was we're going to see for
many other reasons so the beloved is is
essentially the passive object that is
in some way provoking desire provoking
attraction on the part of the more
active lover the Arab states who desires
who feels this what you know confusing
thing that we call love and the lover
acts as well the lover is the one who
makes the phone call and says hey can we
go out Friday night the beloved is the
one who says let me think about it or
says yes or says no I'm busy the beloved
doesn't necessarily do anything in
return and there's no element here of
the beloved you know secretly behind the
scenes being a lover who somehow seduces
the longer on the surface into acting
and all that that's just rather the
beloved is somebody attractive and the
lover acts the lover creates conditions
in which their relationship can can
flourish can be brought to the kind of
fruition that they want can develop all
these sorts of things the beloved is
expected in some way to reward the lover
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
with affection it could be just with
action it could just be hanging him
somebody's arm being on you know they
call icandy your arm candy there's a lot
of possibilities for this to play itself
out now which of these two is greater
greater in what sense morally better
more important perhaps we could think of
it in turn
like having the greatest social approval
there's there's a lot of different ways
we could think of greater what we
actually get out of Phaedra's of speech
is that both of these people are
concerned with what we can call
appearances but appearances in a very
important way they are concerned with
their you know honor or shame they're
their team a or ice I Saccone in the
face of the lover how they appear to the
other person right so the the lover
cares very much about how the beloved
views them and they will go to you know
if there is a not a particularly good
looking person and they think that it's
important to look good looking they will
you know go and get some sort of work
done or you know dress nicer or you know
go and buy a car something like that
right if they think that what matters is
having lots of friends then they will
try to give the impression that they are
they're actually a very social person
who's well liked by others if they think
that you know sense of humor is what's
desirable and they don't have a sense of
humor I don't know exactly what they do
maybe by a joke book or something in
that price some of the jokes but you get
the idea there's there's um there's a
care about how the beloved perceives
them and this can go much deeper doesn't
have to be so superficial it could be
you know where are you getting your
money from are you engaged in shameful
practices in the course of your business
you know maybe you don't want to be that
person anymore the beloved also feel
something like that he says towards the
lover there's something about being
placed in the the orbit of another
person's you know desire that makes you
a little bit more conscious about the
kind of person that you are now for bad
people of course which faders is not
talking about that could lead to the you
know aha I could manipulate this person
I could really take advantage of them
but for good people this should produce
something like a oh wow I'm I've got
somebody who lie
Smee who loves me for the kind of person
that they think I am perhaps even who I
am I really need to live up to this and
so both of them in that sensor are on an
equal playing in many respects he also
says that there's no greater good to
either one of these people than the
other person and hey you know what this
is like when you're when you're involved
in a relationship where suddenly an
attraction springs up you want to spend
all your time possible with that person
you know you're constantly texting
around the phone or you know spending
time face-to-face with them you don't
want to leave that may change as time
goes on you become more familiar with
each other and you know you also get
over the you know are you still going to
be here when I come back sort of worries
but it doesn't just have to do with
spending time you know Phaedra's is
saying there is no greater good uh you
know Agathon a good something that is a
softened translated benefit here to the
other person than the one that either
loves them or the one who they love so
again we see a kind of symmetry going on
or at least they're both on the same
level a little bit different when he
gets to talking about this case of
Achilles and Achilles is going to
provide us with the rule but also with
the violation or the exception to the
rule as well which is going to better
flesh out for us what's going on so when
he's talking about the gods he says the
gods themselves are particularly you
know happy to see they admire these sort
of actions the the affections the
stances that people take that are
motivated by love so the gods look at
lovers and they think that the lover is
in a certain respect better than the
beloved because the lover is being
motivated by love and the lover is the
one who is active the lumber is the one
who is doing things so you know let's
see if we can come up with some
other examples besides that of Achilles
one of my favorites is that of Odysseus
and Penelope now in that case both of
them are doing some pretty amazing stuff
Penelope if you know the story she is
waiting for Odysseus to get home but
she's not waiting in a purely passive
way you know this is made in the tower
you know totally helpless or anything
like that she's got suitors she's got
like little kinglets from the whole
island of Ithaca who are actively
pursuing her and a son who's you know
growing to maturity who she knows that
his soonerlater is going to provoke a
conflict or either he kills them or they
kill him she is trying to get a hold out
for Odysseus so she you know does this
an incredible stratagem of telling them
I need to weave a burial shroud for my
father and for three years she's able to
fool them she we use during the day and
then at night she unweave 'he's the
thing you know getting almost no sleep
until one of her maids finally betrays
her and the suitors are like look lady
you got to make a choice between one a
one of us or the other so that's pretty
good Odysseus for his part is constantly
trying to get back home and not just to
his land not just to being a king not
just to the son that he hasn't seen
since you know he left or the father
that he misses but for his wife and he
is actually offered the chance to become
essentially immortal he you know he does
sleep with two women well two women like
beings on the way he sleeps with with
kir k who's a sorceress and then he also
knocks her up as we find other stories
and then he sleeps with Calypso who is
this divine creature and Calypso offers
him the chance to stay with her instead
he says no I don't want that i want to
go back home in part because he loves
his wife so much so the gods see that
sort of thing and they are very
please buy it they think that this is
wonderful and the lover is able to do
what they do by virtue of the fact that
they feel loved by the fact that the god
of love is within them they are
participating in love the beloved maybe
not so much except in the case of
somebody like Achilles or we might
actually say in the case of somebody
some couple like Odysseus and Penelope
as well in the case of Achilles he is
the younger man he is the aroma known in
the thing and the person that we often
talked about as being his lover or his
beloved is actually his his lover so you
know the way that the passage runs is I
make a special point of this in any case
that God's display admiration for the
valor that Springs from love they are
even more amazed delighted and
beneficent when the beloved in this case
Achilles shows the the same for his
beloved or does the same for his beloved
in this case petrópolis in this case
it's also very interesting patrol clis
by the time that the ultimate gesture of
love is being shown petropoulos is dead
and achilles is taking on a certain
death sooner or later in order to avenge
petrópolis in order to provide his lover
with what he ought to receive from the
beloved so you know how should we
understand this is Achilles thereby
transforming himself into no longer the
beloved but a greater lover in return
one who has more to offer one who is
inhabited by love who acts by love to an
even greater extent perhaps that's the
way that we ought to look at in any case
the gods marvel when a beloved
reciprocate that is does the same in
return or even goes further and the case
of Achilles might be
I stood as either one of these so who is
greater it's still really the lover
because reciprocating really does turn
the beloved into a lover in return in
that case we have some sort of
reciprocal relationship of lover to
lover which means that to answer this
question it's not the beloved the
attractive one who is greater it's the
one who is acting upon who is motivated
by that attraction or that desire the
lover